THIS IS NOT THE LAST YOU'LL SEE
OF SARAH SANDERS.
LET'S MOVE ON.
PRESIDENT TRUMP FACING MASSIVE
BACKLASH AFTER STAYING IN AN
INTERVIEW THAT HE WOULD BE OPEN
TO HEARING DIRT ON HIS 2020
RIVALS FROM FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.
WATCH.
>> YOUR CAMPAIGN, FOREIGNERS, IF
RUSSIA, CHINA, SOMEONE ELSE
OFFERS YOU INFORMATION ON AN
OPPONENT, SHOULD THEY ACCEPT IT
OR CALL THE FBI?
>> President Trump: I THINK
MAYBE YOU DO BOTH.
I THINK YOU MIGHT WANT TO
LISTEN.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
LISTENING.
IF SOMEBODY CALLED FROM A
COUNTRY, NORWAY, WE HAVE
INFORMATION ON YOUR OPPONENT.
OH, I THINK I WANT TO HEAR IT.
>> YOU WANT THAT KIND OF
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTION?
>> President Trump: ITS
NONINTERFERENCE.
THEY HAVE INFORMATION.
I THINK I WOULD TAKE IT.
IF THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG, I
WOULD GO MAYBE TO THE FBI IF I
THOUGHT THERE WAS SOMETHING
WRONG BUT WITH SOMEONE COMES UP
WITH OPPO RESEARCH.
THEY COME UP WITH OPPO RESEARCH.
LET'S CALL THE FBI?
THE FBI DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
AGENTS TO TAKE CARE OF IT BUT
YOU GO AND TALK HONESTLY TO
CONGRESSMAN, THEY'LL DO IT.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE, AND THAT'S THE
WAY IT IS.
IT'S CALLED OPPO RESEARCH.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATIC 2020
CANDIDATES QUICK TO POUNCE.
JOE BIDEN TWEETING IT'S A THREAT
TO OUR NATIONAL SECURITY.
KAMALA HARRIS SAYING THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF IS A NATIONAL
SECURITY THREAT.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND THINK IT'S
TIME FOR CONGRESS TO BEGIN
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS AND
ELIZABETH WARREN ECHOING
GILLIBRAND, ALSO CALLING FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER
HARSHLY CRITICIZING THE
PRESIDENT.
>> THE PRESIDENT GAVE US ONCE
AGAIN EVIDENCE THAT HE DOES NOT
KNOW RIGHT FROM WRONG.
IT'S A VERY SAD THING.
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO BE SO
CAVALIER TO DISREGARD THE
INDIFFERENCE TO LAW AND ANY
SENSE OF ETHICS THAT WHO WE ARE
AS A COUNTRY TO SAY HE WOULD
INVITE FOREIGN INTERVENTION,
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, WITH
GREAT CONFIDENCE HAS PUT FORTH
THAT THE RUSSIANS INTERFERED IN
OUR ELECTION.
IT'S AN ASSAULT ON OUR DEMOCRAC
DEMOCRACY.
>> TO SAY IT'S OKAY TO
INTERFERE, THAT WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT, THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE NO KNOWLEDGE, IS
TO ENCOURAGE RUSSIA, CHINA,
NORTH KOREA, IRAN, TO INTERFERE
IN OUR ELECTIONS WITH NO
RECOURSE.
SHAME, SHAME.
>> Dana: JESSE, I WAS GONE ONE
DAY, AND I GET BACK AND WE'RE
STILL TALKING ABOUT RUSSIA.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY GETTING A LOT
OF ATTENTION TODAY.
>> Jesse: IT MIGHT BE ONE OF
THE DUMBEST CONTROVERSIES IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AND THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DUMB
CONTROVERSIES.
THIS MIGHT TAKE THE CAKE.
GEORGE IS TRYING TO CREATE A
SCANDAL OVER A HYPOTHETICAL.
GEORGE COMES IN, MR. PRESIDENT,
THE AMBASSADOR TO CHINA, YOU
KNOW, HE SAYS TO YOU THAT BERNIE
STIFFED A WAITRESS AT DENNY'S.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
TRUMP SAYS I WOULD LISTEN.
MAYBE I WOULD CALL THE FBI.
IMPEACH!
YOU HAVE TO BE KIDDING ME.
TRUMP GETS WORD THAT BERNIE
STIFFED A WAITRESS AND HAVE TO
CALL THE FBI?
THERE'S A THOUSAND DIFFERENT
HYPOTHETICAL SCENARIOS THAT YOU
COULD BE TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT SAY?
I'D LISTEN.
MAYBE I WOULD CALL THE FBI.
THAT'S ALL HE SAID.
THE LEFT IS FREAKING OUT OVER A
HYPOTHETICAL BUT THEY ARE NOT
LOOKING AT THE REALITY.
HILLARY ACTUALLY DID THIS.
HILLARY PAID A FOREIGN AGENT TO
GET RUSSIAN DIRT AND THEN SHE
USED IT TO WIRETAP.
OR WHAT ABOUT WHEN THOSE FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS PAID MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR THE CLINTON
FOUNDATION WHEN SHE WAS RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT?
OR LITTLE ADAM SCHIFF.
HE WAS ON THE PHONE CALL.
WE HAVE THE AUDIO.
OH, WE HAVE --
THE WHOLE THING IS SO STUPID AND
IT GOES BACK TO THE TRUMP TOWER
MEETING WHERE DON JR. THOUGHT HE
WAS GOING TO GET DIRT ON
HILLARY, DIDN'T GET IT, THEY
DIDN'T HAVE IT.
NO MONEY CHANGED HANDS, LIKE IT
DID WITH THE CLINTONS AND THE
WHOLE MEETING WAS SET UP BY
FUSION GPS.
THIS IS ALL RIDICULOUS.
>> Juan: 'S I TELL YOU, JESSE.
YOU A BIGGER SHOW.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO TRY TO
GET OUT OF THIS.
THIS IS SO RIDICULOUS.
THERE'S A UNITED STATES LAW.
THIS IS NOT A MATTER OF
OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
AS A LAW THAT SAYS YOU CANNOT
ACCEPT MONEY OR IN-KIND
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS.
>> Jesse: SO WE ARE GOING TO
LOCK HILLARY UP?
>> Juan: LET ME FINISH.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHICH
NANCY PELOSI SAID CANNOT TELL
RIGHT FROM WRONG, WE GO FROM
ILLEGAL.
>> Jesse: TELL ME ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
>> Juan: THIS IS TOTALLY
DIFFERENT.
>> Jesse: HOW IS IT DIFFERENT?
>> Juan: FUSION GPS IS
AMERICAN COMPANY.
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, TRUMP'S FBI
DIRECTOR, SAID IT'S WRONG.
WHAT DID TRUMP SAY?
CHRISTOPHER WRAY IS WRONG.
NO, CHRISTOPHER WRAY, THE FBI
DIRECTOR, IS RIGHT.
WHEN YOU TRY TO BLAME AND DERIDE
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS, THIS WAS
NO GOTCHA MOMENT.
>> Jesse: DOING THIS TO EVERY
REPUBLICAN SINCE THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
SINCE YOU'RE NOT COLLUDING,
WOULD YOU ACCEPT FOREIGN DIRT?
>> Juan: ESSENTIALLY YOU ARE
INSULTING THE PRESIDENT BECAUSE
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT
HE'S DOING, KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT
HE'S SAYING.
THIS IS NO GOTCHA MOMENT.
>> Jesse: YOU HAVE NO ANSWER
ON THE DOSSIER.
YOU HAVE NO ANSWER.
WHERE DO THEY GET IT FROM?
>> Katie: FUSION GPS WAS
WORKING WITH CHRISTOPHER STEELE
IS AN AMERICAN OPPOSITION
RESEARCH.
>> Jesse: YOU ARE UPSET OVER
TRUMP.
>> Katie: IF YOU LET ME FINISH
THE SENTENCE.
THE QUESTION IS, DOES IT APPLY
TO EVERYBODY, DOES THE STANDARD
APPLY?
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION, IT
APPARENTLY WAS OKAY TO REACH OUT
WITH CASH AND MONEY TO PAY
FOREIGN ACTORS TO GET RESEARCH
FROM RUSSIAN ADVERSARIAL
SOURCES.
NANCY PELOSI IS SAYING THAT IF
SOMEONE REACHES OUT TO YOU AS A
REPUBLICAN, THAT'S UNETHICAL.
IT'S A CRIMINAL COVER-UP AND
IT'S NOT ALLOWED.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE DOSSIER,
WHEN THE LEFT WAS EXPOSED AS
BEING BEHIND THE FUNDING FOR
THAT, THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN IN
THE DNC, THEY CLAIMED IT WAS
JUST OPPOSITION RESEARCH.
DOESN'T MATTER THAT IT CAME FROM
A FOREIGN SOURCE OR WHO THE
SOURCE WAS.
WE WERE DOING OUR JOB AS OF THAT
CAMPAIGN TO GET INFORMATION.
BUT WHEN THE PRESIDENT USES THE
SAME ARGUMENT FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE SAYING HE MIGHT CALL
THE FBI BUT HE'S GOING TO LISTEN
TO THE INFORMATION, THEN ALL OF
A SUDDEN THEY ARE CALLING FOR
MORE IMPEACHMENT ON THE BASIS
THAT HE'S A CRIMINAL.
WELL, THERE'S A DOUBLE STANDARD.
DO WE WANT FOREIGN INTERFERENCE
IN OUR ELECTIONS?
NO.
THERE ARE REASONS WHY WE HAVE
LAWS ABOUT FOREIGN DONATIONS AND
FOREIGN MONEY BEING USED FOR
CAMPAIGNS.
BUT IF ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
THIS, THERE'S GOING TO BE A
WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., WHO WERE
GUILTY OF COLLUDING OR USING
INFORMATION FROM FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS, INCLUDING
DEMOCRATS, TO INTERFERE IN
ELECTIONS.
>> Dana: TOM HASN'T HAD A
CHANCE TO TALK YET.
>> Tom: DEMOCRATS, DON'T TALK
TO NORWAY.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO TAKE
THE CALL.
>> Dana: THE PRESS SECRETARY
TODAY.
>> Tom: JESSE, YOU ARE DEAD
ON.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
THE STORIES RIDICULOUS.
IT WAS A FABRICATED STORY
BECAUSE GEORGE PLANTED --
WHAT WOULD YOU DO IF THIS?
I WISH THE PRESIDENT WOULD SAY
I'M GLAD I DIDN'T CONTACT THE
FDA LAST TIME AROUND BECAUSE THE
GUY WHO WAS RUNNING THE FBI WAS
WORKING AGAINST ME.
THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE WHEN YOU
SHOULDN'T CALL THE FBI, WHEN THE
HEAD OF THE FBI IS WORKING FOR
THE OTHER CAMPAIGN, WHICH IS
WHAT HAPPENED.
>> Jesse: PAPADOPOULOS
CONTACTED THE FBI'S AT THESE
FOREIGN AGENTS ARE TRYING TO SPY
ON ME.
WHAT DO THEY DO TO HIM?
>> Juan: LET ME TELL YOU.
YOU ARE COVERING UP FOR
SOMETHING THAT'S INEXCUSABLE.
REMEMBER, WHEN THEY GIVE YOU
THIS INFORMATION, THEY HAVE
HOOKS AND YOU AND YOU ARE NOT
REPRESENTING THE BEST INTERESTS
OF OUR COUNTRY.
EITHER YOU'RE WORKING FOR THE
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT OR YOU'RE
WORKING --
>> Jesse: WORKING FOR --
>> Dana: WAS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY.
I'M TERRIFIED OF GETTING IN
TROUBLE.
I WOULD ALWAYS CALL THE FBI.
I DO EVER WANT TO GET IN TROUBLE
AND IF THE RUSSIAN AND CHINESE
OR THE NORWEGIANS OR SWISS, IF
THEY CALLED ME WITH INFORMATION,
I WOULD CALL.
BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD SAY
WHAT ABOUT THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION?
WHAT WERE THEY DOING TO PREVENT
INTERFERENCE IN OUR ELECTION?
I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THE ANSWER
TO THAT, GEORGE, FLIP IT ON HIM.
DOING A REALLY IMPORTANT BIG
INTERVIEW TO BROADEN YOUR REACH
AND THE INTERVIEW, EVEN THOUGH
THEY TALKED ABOUT THE ECONOMY A